نبقى في ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وفي
تطوراته الميدانيه ايضا قال حاكم مقاطعه
دونيتك كانوكراني لاربعه مدنيين قتلوا امس
في قصف روسيا على مناطق سيطره الجيش
الاوكراني في المقاطعه وقالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان قواتها افشلت محاولات تسلل
لقوات فاجنر الى مدينه بخمود شرقيه
المقاطعه وان القوات الروسيه شنت هجمات
باتجاه مدن مارينت وافريقيا كما اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني وعن مقتل نحو 150 جنديا
روسيا في قصف على مطار فيك خوفك في مقاطعه
خرسون جنوبيه البلاد
قالت الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه خرسون ان شخصا على الاقل قتل واصيب
اخرون في قصف روسي على مدينه خرسون واوضحت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه استهدفت منطقه السفن في المدينه
الواقعه جنوبيه البلاد